así es muy buenas tardes pues
efectivamente en una semana los
contagios han aumentado prácticamente en
el doble el día domingo había un poco
más de 4000 casos mientras que hace una
semana esa cifra estaba por los 2000 por
eso precisamente llegó pues esta
alocución desde el presidente de manuela
marco hablando de nuevas medidas que hay
que tomar desde ahora para evitar lo que
ya se venía hablando desde hace varias
semanas y es que para finales de julio
pues francia podría estar abocada a ver
una nueva ola una cuarta ola de
contagios y como usted lo bien lo decía
quest y las hospitalizaciones están
disminuyendo hay menos de 1000 personas
hospitalizadas en digamos en cuidados
intensivos pero el número de casos va
aumentando y lo que se teme es
precisamente que con ese número
exponencial de casos que podría estar
incluso por los 20.000 casos diarios
para el mes de agosto pues eso haga
también que aumente una vez más la
presión en los hospitales y por eso
precisamente se ve pues todo este
paquete de medidas mucho menos digamos
ser restrictivas que lo que se ha vivido
durante estos últimos 18
meses aquí en francia pero que buscan
precisamente que el país no vuelva a
estar sometido a nuevos o confinamientos
aunque tal vez ustedes lo escucharon a
partir del día de mañana en los
territorios de ultramar como la reunión
y como dominica pues ahí pues habrá un
toque de queda a partir de mañana por el
alza en los contagios natalia algo que
llamaba mucho la atención y que ya se
había escuchado en algún punto era que
el presidente iba a ser la vacunación
obligatoria para el personal de salud en
principio porque a pesar de que ha sido
un público que ha tenido disponible las
vacunas
desde el primer momento no todos se han
vacunado como cómo se recibe esta
noticia cómo se recibe esta confirmación
entre estas personas no suelo los
personales dios el personal de
hospitales sino también de casas de
cuidados de mayores y de personas con
algún tipo de discapacidad
pues eso es todo un debate que va a
girar por eso el presidente en algún
momento de su discurso dice que habrá
que ver más adelante si se piensa en o
no en que haya una vacunación
obligatoria para todos los franceses
pero por ahora lo que sí venía hablando
se era de esta vacunación obligatoria
para el personal sanitario para todas
aquellas personas que trabajen por
ejemplo en residencias de mayores esto
con el fin de proteger a las personas
más vulnerables personas que estén pues
que tengan algún tipo de enfermedad y
las personas mayores que son finalmente
las que son más afectadas por el la
comida 19 en los días antes después de
esta alocución ya se estaba hablando de
esto era sobre todo algunos sindicatos
los que estaban en contra de esta
imposición pero en realidad por ejemplo
el consejo científico que es el que
viene asesorando al gobierno desde hace
un poco más de un año respecto a todo lo
que tiene que ver con esta pandemia pues
estaban en pro precisamente de esto pero
también muchas voces del personal médico
que pedían también que la vacunación no
fuera obligatoria y bueno pues es un
hecho ya es obligatorio y sobre todo
pues tienen de aquí al 15 de septiembre
como lo decía
en su discurso para vacunarse y a partir
de ese momento pues habrá controles y
sanciones para quienes no lo estén otro
punto clave del anuncio del mandatario
fue la implementación del pase sanitario
para actividades mucho más diarias mucho
más comunes antes se pedía para
festivales para estas grandes reuniones
y ahora será para cafés para
restaurantes para centros comerciales
para aviones y trenes de larga distancia
cómo se ve esto en francia
pues habrá que ver cuál es la digamos la
respuesta de los franceses respecto a
esto hubo algunos pequeños sondeos en
varios medios que le preguntaban a la
gente por ejemplo en los cafés en los
restaurantes que opinaban de este paso
sanitario que se impusiera en los
restaurantes en los cafés y la gente por
lo general pues estaba en realidad de
acuerdo porque la gente lo que quiere es
volver de alguna manera a esa vida de
antes tener la libertad de poder salir a
comer a un restaurante de tomarse un
café de ir a un concierto o ir en este
caso pues por ejemplo a un a un parque
de atracciones y a partir de pues de
este de este 21 de julio ese paseo será
obligatorio para por ejemplo ir a un
parque de diversiones todos estos son
lugares de donde haya un poco más de 50
personas digamos que quienes estaban un
poco más reticentes a esta idea son más
bien quiénes son los dueños de los
restaurantes y de los bares porque
pensaban que esto pues iba a hacer que
mucha gente pues no quiera por ejemplo
ir a estos lugares y punto también
importante lo que usted decía claro
también hablaba de este pase sanitario
para
las personas que van a tomar un tren o
un avión de larga distancia pero no
solamente para los pasajeros sino
también para los empleados para quienes
estén trabajando en aviones y trenes